well we all know that the migrant crisis
is far from over even though of course
scenes of boats traveling from France of
the UK are becoming much less and less
frequent but according to an undercover
report by LBC an alleged people smuggler
is claiming that the French authorities
are even helping him and his team
sneaked migrants across the channel some
time Vinny's people going with him
because police want you to get out of
France yes they want to go well there
you saw the film the secret filming by
LBC of the alleged people smuggler the
man in charge of that team there in
Dunkirk in France he goes by the name
for Rukh and as the video goes on he
seems to be explaining that the French
authorities are advising him and his
team when is best to attempt a crossing
and when is best to hold back
potentially possibly because they
themself have inside information as to
when the UK border force is in operation
and patrolling the channel so there in
that report it seems at best the French
authorities are turning a blind eye but
at worst actively engaging and helping
that whole operation that though is
something that the French police Verint
Li deny meanwhile then the home office
here in Britain is saying that the
French counterparts with British
operations have this joint plan of
action and says that the two have a very
close working relationship the organized
crime groups behind the illegal attempts
to cross the channel are putting the
lives of vulnerable people in serious
danger for their own financial gain we
are determined to put a stop to this
illegal activity well according to this
undercover report it's apparently known
that up to seven thousand pounds of
being charged to those people that want
to go towards the United Kingdom it's
understood that Farook he himself has
led up to four hundred people across the
channel the ring is said to be in
operation in London Birmingham and of
course Dunkirk there in France now a
follow-up report sees that Farook is
Vinh
denying himself any involvement in all
of these allegations now last month we
know that the Home Secretary Prieta
Patel
met with the French counterparts to
discuss this joint action plan to stop
vessels from attempting any crossing
across the English Channel and just
today she then advocated tighter border
controls
you